[Música]
rosa dejar que ellos nos cuenten qué
significa que es el taekwondo que es el
taekwondo para vos me caer y que ha sido
en tu vida bueno el té cuando yo lo
comencé desde chiquito porque viene de
familia mi mamá es mi profesora fue mi
guía en este camino así que este cuando
en mi vida es como un pilar reforzó mis
valores me dio autocontrol cortesía
perseverancia espíritu indómito y lo
logró reforzar y para resumir el
taekwondo para mí es pasión es una forma
de vida
contanos cómo es que los dos son
campeones mundiales 2019 como el sexto
posible de campeones mundiales en el
mismo año
bueno hace años atrás en el 2002
percepción general soy quien fue el
creador de toda esta pasión que
manejamos nosotros y muchos más
y bueno quedaron un par de personas a
cargo podría decirse como para que me
entiendan y éstas fueron dividendo sea a
través del tiempo logrando que sea armen
cintas líneas o distintas ramas en donde
en una pertenecer en otra pertenezco yo
y muchos más entonces hay torneos en los
que nos cruzamos en regionales en
panamericanos en copas del mundo como el
año pasado que nos fuimos australia's
juntos pero no en mundiales o de más
participaciones pero ahora próximamente
seguramente se crucen en uno sí sí el
año que viene tenemos en vista otra copa
del mundo juntos que nos toca que es en
eslovenia en 2020 muy bien y yo digo
[Aplausos]
e instancias pasaron con quienes te
diste que pelear mikael para llegar a
ser campeón mundial
bueno yo fui a korea muy limpia a las
olimpiadas de artes marciales y fueron
alrededor de 36 países competir contra
unos estadounidenses dos alemanes
de nueva zelanda de australia y después
eso era un par de rondas era un grupo y
el ganador de ese grupo iba contra los
coreanos que los coreanos eran un grupo
separado porque eran muchos entonces
después competir toda la rama de
coreanos y logré salir campeón mundial
en taekwondo y también en hard on mundo
en corte
y dar alas a los coreanos acá los
alemanes
cuál es el sueño
el sueño principal para un agonista o
creería yo que para cualquier otro
deporte es representar al país en
nuestro caso argentina que para varios
de los más importantes así que llegar a
eso llegar a competir y bueno ganar como
logramos por suerte creo que es uno de
los sueños más grandes pero igual uno de
los más difíciles ya que cuando llegas
cuando no estás que pudiste lograr lo
que tanto querías lo más difícil se te
viene después porque es tratar de
mantener se trata de seguir obteniendo
logros y llegar en el podio
constantemente y qué hay que hacer para
mantenerse
para mantenerse ahí hay que perseverar
hay que entrenar mucho enfocarte en eso
dedicarle mucho tiempo muchas horas en
tu vida y lo vas a lograr con la ayuda
de tu profesor siempre que se puede no
lo puede lograr hay que seguir y seguir
campeones mundiales detalles cuando un
aplauso fuertísimo para eso porque son
de acá de nuestra ciudad
sus profesores de acá esto es un
esfuerzo enorme porque no es solamente
el entrenamiento las ganas después de
esperar desde comodoro rivadavia hasta
corea económicamente es un esfuerzo
enorme así que los felicito chicos son
un ejemplo de nuestra ciudad muchas
gracias
[Música]